-Au niveau financier,
Mme Chalus,
comment ça se passe pour vous ?
-Bon ben pour ma maman,
la retraite étant
autour de 1100 euros,
il manque 800
ou 900 euros par mois.
-D'accord, mettons,
mettons 1000 euros par mois.
Ca fait 12 000 euros par an,
fois 10 ans,
ça fait 120 000 euros,
pour une personne.
-Oui.
-De grosses sommes.
Bonjour.
Christine Pirès Beaune,
députée de la 2e circonscription
du Puy-de-Dôme.
En juillet dernier,
j'ai remis à la Première ministre
un rapport
à sa demande
sur le reste à charge
en établissement, en EHPAD,
pour les résidents.
-C'est dans le Puy-de-Dôme,
autour de la ville de Riom,
dans sa circonscription,
que la députée socialiste
Christine Pirès Beaune
a été interpellée par des familles
qui n'arrivaient plus
à payer la place en EHPAD
de leurs parents.
Elle a cherché à savoir
comment fonctionnait le système.
-Bonjour, vous allez bien ?
-Ca va bien, merci.
-APA, allocation logement,
aides sociales...
Les familles sont soutenues,
mais le reste à charge,
comme on dit,
est souvent important :
2100 euros aussi
chaque mois.
-C'est Marie.
-C'est le rapport
sur le reste à charge
en EHPAD qui nous conduit
ce matin à venir vous voir.
-Vous êtes la bienvenue,
comme toujours.
-Vous avez combien de résidents ?
-68.
-Parmi eux, Antonia,
arrivée ici il y a 2 ans.
Depuis, ses enfants doivent
se serrer la ceinture
pour payer chaque mois,
surtout que,
paradoxalement, les plus modestes
sont les moins aidés.
-BONJOUR.
-Bonjour.
-Bonjour, madame.
-Ca va bien ?
-On est à peu près
à 1100 euros de reste à charge,
à diviser en 8 personnes.
On est 8 frères et soeurs.
On règle chacun 136 euros
par personne.
-Par mois.
-Actuellement, je suis sans emploi,
donc forcément,
avec mes charges locatives,
résidentielles, etc.,
c'est une charge supplémentaire
qui est pas négligeable.
Sachant qu'aujourd'hui,
je suis non imposable,
je n'ai pas d'avantage fiscal,
contrairement à ma soeur qui,
par exemple,
peut avoir une petite
déduction d'imposition.
-Effectivement, si votre maman
était à domicile,
vous auriez toutes les deux,
tous les huit, d'ailleurs,
une aide fiscale
qu'on appelle un crédit d'impôt,
alors que quand on est
en établissement,
seules les personnes imposables...
Quand on est imposable,
on a plus de moyens
que quand on ne l'est pas.
Quand on paie des impôts,
on a plus de moyens
que celui qui n'en paie pas.
Là, contre-intuitivement,
on a une aide fiscale.
C'est vrai que c'est
particulièrement injuste.
-Plus de 3/4
des résidents en EHPAD
ne peuvent payer
ce reste à charge
sans vendre leurs biens
et surtout faire appel
à leurs enfants.
Pour la députée,
il est temps de tout revoir
pour rendre le système plus juste
et plus simple aussi.
-En fait, aujourd'hui,
on a un système d'aides
beaucoup trop compliqué,
avec 4 aides pour 5 milliards
d'argent public, quand même.
Donc, on a de l'argent public
pour aider les gens,
sauf que c'est incompréhensible
pour les résidents,
pour les familles.
Plutôt que d'avoir
ce maquis de soutien financier,
je propose
une seule aide universelle,
c'est-à-dire pour tous les résidents
en EHPAD
et qui est dégressive
en fonction des revenus, simplement.
-Pour aider les familles
quand les gens vivent
toujours plus âgés,
Christine Pirès Beaune
veut créer une sorte de bouclier.
Au bout de trois
ou quatre ans,
les descendants ne seraient plus
mis à contribution
et la solidarité nationale
prendrait totalement en charge
le prix de l'EHPAD.
Car le système actuel
donne lieu
à des situations ubuesques.
Quand les familles
ne s'entendent pas,
dans certains départements,
les petits-enfants peuvent
être mis à contribution.
-Y a quelques années,
c'était des petits-enfants
qui sont venus me parler
de cette obligation alimentaire
qu'ils comprenaient pas
et qui était compliquée,
en plus,
à gérer pour eux,
parce qu'ils avaient
des enfants en bas âge,
ils avaient pas de gros salaires
mais des salaires normaux.
C'était compliqué.
-Les enfants ne touchant
que de petites retraites,
les petits-enfants
furent sollicités.
-Donc, y a pas eu accord
de la famille,
y a saisie du juge
aux affaires familiales qui tranche
et qui leur avait demandé
100 euros par mois.
Donc, c'est vrai que,
pour eux, c'était incompréhensible,
sachant que la dame en question
avait trois enfants.
-Ce qui est paradoxal,
c'est que la dame
avait une maison
qui aurait pu être vendue.
-Apparemment, elle avait un bien
qui aurait pu effectivement
être vendu.
Mais pour être vendu,
il faut que les enfants
soient d'accord.
Ils étaient pas d'accord
pour vendre ce bien,
parce qu'ils savaient que,
au moment de l'héritage,
il leur reviendrait.
Voilà.
-Dans sa volonté
de réformer le système,
la députée socialiste
a obtenu une première victoire
il y a quelques jours seulement.
-La semaine dernière,
dans le cadre
de la loi Bien vieillir,
à l'Assemblée nationale,
à l'unanimité,
on a voté l'article
qui met fin à l'obligation
alimentaire pour les petits-enfants.
-Comme le montre
le rapport de la députée,
le prix moyen du reste à charge
en EHPAD est de 2000 euros,
aujourd'hui, en France,
avec de grandes disparités
selon les régions :
1600 euros pour la Haute-Saône,
plus de 3500 euros pour Paris
ou les Hauts-de-Seine,
et parfois le sentiment
de ne pas en avoir pour son argent.
Ici, à l'EHPAD rattaché
à l'hôpital public de Riom,
Brigitte Chalus est un peu
la porte-parole des familles.
Pour chaque personne âgée,
c'est 2000 euros.
-On visite la maison de retraite
avec le directeur.
Ma maman, ma tata.
-Bonjour.
-On voit les locaux.
-C'est pas mal.
-Oui.
Voilà, c'est pas mal.
Félicitations du jury.
Mme Chalus rit.
-Brigitte Chalus est ironique,
car en réalité,
la maison de retraite est,
disons, dans son jus
depuis les années 70,
avec des équipements
plus fatigués encore
que les résidents eux-mêmes.
-BONJOUR.
-Vous avez un ascenseur
qui est étroit
et qui fonctionne pas toujours.
La dernière fois,
il était en panne.
-On le répare
pour la dernière fois.
Après, il n'est plus réparable.
Quand vous avez
un seul ascenseur dans l'EHPAD
et qu'il tombe en panne,
vous faites tout
avec la force des bras
et des jambes.
-Un personnel en difficulté,
des locaux vétustes...
Autant dire que tout cela
a des conséquences sur le bien-être
des personnes âgées.
-Là, c'est la douche du 1er étage.
-Donc, une seule douche
pour combien de chambres ?
-Y a 2 douches
pour 68 résidents.
-D'accord.
-Une au 1er, une au 3e.
Ce qui fait que c'est
une douche par semaine
pour chaque résident.
Le reste du temps,
c'est des toilettes au lavabo.
-D'accord.
-Une douche par semaine
dans le meilleur des cas,
quand tout fonctionne.
Heureusement, tout cela
sera bientôt du passé,
car l'EHPAD va
totalement être refait à neuf.
-Le projet consiste
en la reconstruction
de 130 lits d'EHPAD
en lieu et place
de l'EHPAD des Jardins
et de l'EHPAD Pasteur.
Vous voyez ici
l'EHPAD des Jardins existant,
et ici,
l'actuel parking du personnel.
-Brigitte Chalus a du mal
à se réjouir,
car au total,
l'investissement s'élève
à plus de 21 millions d'euros,
un coût qu'il va
bien falloir répercuter
sur le prix que chaque résident
paie tous les mois.
-C'est une dizaine
d'euros supplémentaires
sur les prix journée hébergement.
-Par jour.
Christine Pirès Beaune acquiesce.
-C'est conséquent.
-Par mois, ça fait ?
-Par mois, ça fait 300.
-C'est déjà compliqué,
aujourd'hui, donc là,
si on a une augmentation
trop conséquente,
y a des personnes
qui ne pourront pas
rester à l'EHPAD sur Riom.
-L'ARS va donner une subvention
de 4 millions d'euros.
Si le département met aussi
la main au portefeuille,
cela pourrait faire
baisser la facture.
Mais pour épargner les familles,
la députée pense
que ce n'est pas assez.
-Ce que j'ai écrit dans le rapport,
c'est que, que ce soit
des projets de restructuration,
de construction, d'humanisation,
plus vous mettez de subventions,
et pas d'avances remboursables,
de subventions,
plus vous maîtrisez
le reste à charge,
parce que vous aurez
moins de frais financiers
et le reste à charge pourra
plus être maîtrisé
par les équipes en place.
-En réalité,
peu d'EHPAD arrivent
à maîtriser leurs coûts.
Ici, en Auvergne-Rhône-Alpes,
85 % des établissements affichent
des déficits en fin d'année.
Il y a des contre-exemples.
La députée veut s'en inspirer
dans son travail.
Nous sommes à 60 km
de Clermont-Ferrand,
et cette maison de retraite
est classée 3e meilleure de France
pour le bien-être de ses résidents
parmi les 7400 de notre pays.
-Bonjour, vous allez bien ?
-Bien, merci.
Salut, Didier.
Merci de nous accueillir.
-Bienvenue à l'EHPAD de Giat.
-Mais en plus, cet EHPAD a
une situation financière saine,
ce qui lui permet
de maintenir les coûts.
-On va voir nos résidents.
Bonjour, tout le monde !
-BONJOUR !
-Pour réussir le tour de force
de maintenir les coûts
en apportant une qualité de service,
l'EHPAD a tout misé
sur son personnel.
-Vous faites quoi,
aujourd'hui, alors ?
-Chamboule-tout.
Fracas métallique
-Quand, ailleurs,
on peine à trouver du personnel,
ici, les salariées
restent longtemps
et l'absentéisme est quasi nul.
-Chez nous,
les animatrices, c'est pas juste
"je réaliste le chamboule-tout".
C'est des animations
individuelles le matin,
où elles vont voir
tous les résidents
qui peuvent pas participer
aux animations collectives.
Elles vont faire des massages,
de la lecture,
de la discussion
et plein d'autres choses.
-D'être là depuis longtemps
et d'avoir assez de personnel
pour tout le monde,
c'est ce qu'il y a de mieux
pour les résidents.
Quand on regarde ailleurs, c'est...
C'est tout l'opposé.
-Chouchouter ses salariées,
c'est vertueux pour les finances
de l'EHPAD
et pour celle des résidents.
-On y gagne
à tous les points de vue,
d'avoir un personnel qui...
Même si c'est, après,
un personnel qui, du coup,
demande des échelons,
à être valorisé,
c'est toujours moins cher
qu'un intérimaire
qu'il faut rémunérer
quand même presque deux fois plus
qu'un personnel soignant basique.
Allez, Lucienne.
La directrice rit.
-Ici, on a fait un choix différent
de la majorité des EHPAD :
on n'a ni psychologue,
ni médecin coordonnateur
mais deux animatrices
à temps plein
pour 39 résidents seulement.
-On a une aide-soignante
qui fait un groupe patois.
Ils se rappellent leurs traditions,
ce qu'ils faisaient avant.
-La députée préconise
de chercher de nouvelles
sources de financement.
Comme le rapport Libault
avant elle,
elle estime qu'il manque
10 milliards d'euros par an
pour la dépendance.
-On parle de transition énergétique,
mais l'autre mur devant nous,
c'est la transition démographique.
Nous, on a eu un baby-boom.
On va avoir un papy-boom,
on va l'avoir.
On le sait,
c'est pas des projections,
c'est une réalité
qui est documentée,
qui est sûre.
Il faut que les pouvoirs publics
dégagent les moyens financiers.
Il n'y a pas d'argent magique,
ça passera
par des recettes supplémentaires.
Passez une bonne soirée !
-Christine Pirès Beaune espère
que les éléments de son rapport
seront repris dans la loi
grand âge...
-Ca nous touche.
-Au revoir.
...que le gouvernement a promis
de faire voter en 2024.
Musique légère
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA